- Have you ever tried to reheat fast food?
I find myself always chasing
that level of deliciousness,
that like "chomp, chomp,
chomp" right when you get it.
It's so good every single time.
Fast food fries are
just one of those foods
that is just superior to most things.
So for this video,
I'm going to be testing
all the ways I can think of
to reheat fast food,
to get as close as I can to
being as good as possible.
We're going to focus on two
staples, burger and fries.
We got to put all of these
burgers in the fridge.
(boxes falling)
(oh no!)
I almost forgot about our sack of fries.
(bag crinkling)
Through the magic of editing,
we are ready to start.
I don't know why I did that.
This is going to give us a good sense
of where our starting line
for each test is going to be.
The fact that I can grip the top bun
and everything just kind of stays.
Like I really think.
(gasping)
- Cold fries, not good.
Cross section here.
With our question, the
simplest reheating technique,
we're talking microwave.
Go here.
(cheering)
- Burger here.
(microwave door closing)
- I'm going to start with a minute
and then just kind of
eyeball it from there.
"Sitting on the floor in
front of the microwave."
Even though it's only been 20 seconds,
I am smelling a lot of,
let's go 10 more seconds.
(go, go, go)
- All right. That's enough.
The bun is very hot.
The fries are very hot, but I
don't like what I'm feeling.
It's been less than a minute.
It smells like fast food.
I can feel the heat, like
radiating off of this.
Microwave. Come on!
It's the right temperature
of what you want a french fry to be,
but it is so limp.
I expected that.
And I don't know if there's a
way to really get around that
from a microwave, but.
The burger, I have a little
more faith in, honestly.
It's so hot!
(gasping)
- Shocking, electrifying.
The bun has lost a lot.
It's basically the same
texture as the burger.
Guys, what are we going to do?
I am sweating so bad.
There's a lot of things
going right for microwave,
that took literally no time at all.
And the burger patty is pretty ideal.
The microwave burger gets, I got to go 7.
I'm thinking what the end
of this video should be
is borrowing the perfect cooking technique
for each ingredient,
to then construct the
ultimate reheat method.
We're going to go oven.
350 sounds like a pretty
decent starting point.
I think I'm going to wrap
the whole thing in foil
and toss some fries on the side.
(foil crinkling)
- I want to make sure they all have room.
Toss that in.
It's been about 5 minutes.
Ooh, sizzling a little bit.
I'm going to give that a little flip.
Toss around.
AlRight. It's been about 10 minutes.
I think it's time to eat our oven test.
Ooh, hot, hot, hot.
Immediate thoughts.
I'm liking the way the fries look.
The fries are serious.
If these were in the oven for any longer,
they would have started drying out.
There's a good crisp. The
cheese is melty again.
The bun is a little crispy on the outside.
Hmm. Let's talk about it.
It's cooked more evenly throughout
than I thought it would be.
Taking into consideration the
burger and fries together,
out of 10, like a 7 1/2.
It's really strong.
Time to bust out some pans.
I think for our pan method,
this is definitely going
to be a deconstruction.
Don't break.
My plan was to put the
burger patty in the skillet
and also have the buns
kind of heat up next to it separately.
I think we just got to see what happens.
I'm going to put the buns in cold.
Soften up a little bit.
I'll take them out before adding the patty
and then I'll put our fries
in our second skillet.
How cocky will he get with the fries?
This bun, I'm confident
that I can flip over
and kind of toast on both sides.
Test. They're not cold anymore.
Could be crisper.
I don't want to forget about these buns.
I think I'm going to pull that off.
Let's go burger in.
I forgot that the cheese
and condiments and pickles
are all going to be stuck to it.
The fries have been going
for about 5 minutes.
So I think we're going to turn that off
from about medium heat.
And I want you guys to hear this.
(sizzling)
- I'm going to put this on our...
Is there cheese on the bottom too?
Newly assembled pan burger.
While it may be more annoying
to constantly shake a
pan around full of fries,
those are better than the oven.
Everything still feels warm and hot.
Hmm, that is quite nice.
The button is still light and fluffy.
It's not dried out like
it was in the oven.
It's heated all the way through
because we separated everything.
I got to go like 8 1/2.
I know that's a big jump
from our oven score.
I have little to no idea
how this next method is going to go.
Air fryer. Plug. She awakens.
(beeps)
- Let's go 350.
(sliding drawer)
- Nice and hot. Little baddy in here.
I'll keep an eye on you.
Fries in, everybody's situated.
(drawer closing)
- I'm thinking around probably 5 minutes.
Then we're going to take another peek.
Maybe flip.
Maybe toss a couple of guys around.
In 5 minutes.
Oh, oh. Oh no.
(fries sliding out pan)
- I didn't think 5 minutes
would be a long time in the air fryer.
However, the fries look good.
Let's give the fries a shot first.
Mhmm. A little dry.
(knife sliding against table)
- Oh boy.
Little crunchy.
(crunch)
- Hmm. Realistically, most of
the bun is pretty dried out.
The burger is still heated
through really nicely,
which I didn't expect.
For the air fryer,
fries and burger, 7.
(finger tapping)
- Now I think the most
important part comes into play.
What pieces do I use
to construct the ultimate reheated
fast food burger and fry.
We're going to put the fries in the pan.
We are preheating the oven
so that we can put the
burger bun in the oven.
And as for the patty itself,
wild card, we are going
to go full microwave
on the burger patty.
(comedic music)
- Delightful. Now,
(operatic music)
Hot. Got to take a lap.
This is how you reheat a
fast food burger and fries.
It may sound like a lot was happening,
but in reality this all took
place in under 5 minutes,
with really common household items.
Absolutely worth the effort.
Thank you for watching.
Let me know in the comments,
what other common fast food items
you want me to test in terms
of reheating techniques.
And then we'll try and Frankenstein
our own perfect method.
Bye bye.
(operatic music)